[Applause]
well I know I know I know the st.
Patrick it's st. Patrick's Day tomorrow
it's not about me it's st. Patrick's as
if we need another reason to drink boy
no more of those kiss me I'm Irish
buttons in the me2 era oh yeah I saw one
today said kiss me I'll sue your ass
yeah the Irish Prime Minister was at the
White House at least we honor that
tradition still gave gave Trump the bowl
of shamrock a plan from Ireland for a
plan from Russia I gotta talk about
Russia too I mean it's good to know you
know that Trump is at the helm when you
hear about new attacks as we did this
week from Russia homeland security did
you see this says that Russian hackers
have been in our infrastructure since
March of 2016 I'm talking about the
electric grid and they're saying they
could turn it off now nuclear power also
aviation systems that could be the
scariest they say the Russians already
have the capability to create utter
chaos by calling all for boarding groups
at once
no but with Russia this is the week this
is the week that Robert Muller crossed
the Rubicon because he subpoenaed
Trump's business records you know you
know cuz Trump always said this is his
redline you know don't look at my
business records well that's where the
whole game is and I think this has made
the president crazier than ever I mean
the shakeups at the Trump White House
and casino just gone into overdrive we
have a new secretary of state you know
Rex Tillerson got the ax on Tuesday he
seems at peace with it he said I've
undone all I can undo here so Rex was
replaced at state by the CIA director
Mike Pompeo and the new top deputy at
state is Heather Nord who was used to be
on Fox and Friends and Gary Cohen who
got shit-canned last week as the chief
economic adviser is being replaced by
Larry Kudlow who Trump watches on CNBC
you see a pattern here next week he's
replacing Jeff sessions with Matlock
it's justice on TV and that's not all
other cabinet people the heads of
cabinets who are about to be fired they
say the housing dude that's ben Carson
Veterans Affairs guy is ready to go
National Security Adviser again we're
gonna be without one of those and the
people who remain just switch the jobs
the CIA director is replacing the
Secretary of State and it looks like the
energy secretary is going to be
replacing the VA secretary and he wants
the EPA had to be replacing the Attorney
General and Ivanka's replacing Melania
but other than that
[Applause]
he's not running a government he's
running a temp agency it's it's like
he's calling a square dance swing your
partner dosey doe Rex is gone here's
Pompeii oh it's not normal young people
not normal even Trump wives are starting
to leave Don juniors wife did you see
this yes yes yes Donny [ __ ] has his
wife filed for divorce she's citing
irreconcilable douchiness says says she
wants to see other creaks no but it's
sad we don't need look we don't know why
they broke up you never really know
right with a couple but I'm gonna go
with hope pics but let's end another
unbelievable week in the Trump era with
an A week by the way he was here in
California for the first time you see
that he he went wall shopping he was he
went to San Diego to look at swatches
but let's but let's end on a positive
note there was a special election in
Pennsylvania litter liberals are very
happy that this guy Connor Lam is the
apparent winner they say he is a new
kind of Democrat because he won he won
something and I love this Trump went to
Pennsylvania campaigned against him of
course landed him the second Connor Lam
won Trump said well he won because he's
like me like me he's this guy's 33 years
old has a full head of hair when he
looks down naked he can see his penis he
was in the Marine Corps he's never gone
bankrupt never colluded with the
Russians never paid hush money to a porn
store other than that it's like looking
in the mirror